Nick Bostrom so you have already given
us so many crazy ideas out there like I
think a couple decades ago you made the
case that we might all be living in
simulation props probably were more
recently I painted most vivid examples
of how artificial general intelligence
could go horribly wrong and now this
year you're about to publish a paper
that presents something called the
vulnerable world hypothesis and our job
this evening is to kind of give the
illustrated guide to that so let's do
that
what is that hypothesis it's trying to
think about sort of structural feature
of the current human condition we can
maybe I mean you're like the urn
metaphor so I'm gonna use that to
explain it's a picture a big urn filled
with balls representing ideas methods
possible technologies you can think of
the history of human creativity as the
process of reaching into this urn and
pulling up one ball after another and
the net effect so far has been hugely
beneficial right we've extracted a great
many white ball some various shades of
grey mixed blessings we haven't so far
pull out the black ball a technology
that invariably destroys the
civilization that discovers it so the
paper tries to think about what could
such a black ball be um so you define
that ball as one that would inevitably
bring about civilizations less we exit
what I call the semi anarchic default
condition but sort of by default so you
make the case compelling by showing some
sort of counter examples where you
believe that so far we've actually got
lucky that we might have thought out
that death ball without even even
knowing it so there's this quote what's
this quote well I guess it's just meant
to illustrate the difficulty of
foreseeing what basic discoveries will
lead to we
just don't have that capability because
we have become quite good at calling out
balls but we don't really have the
ability to put the ball back into the
earth right so we can invent but we can
pendant right and so it's our strategy
such as it is is to hope that there is
no black ball in the earth so so once
it's out its out not you can't put it
back in and you think we've we've been
lucky so talk through a couple of these
numbers I mean you talk about different
types of vulnerability so the easiest
type to understand is a technology that
just makes it very easy to cast massive
amounts of destruction synthetic power
it might be a second source of that kind
of black ball but many many other
possible things we could think of the
engineering would be really great right
we could combat global warming but you
don't want it to get too easy there you
don't want any random person and his
grandmother to have the ability to
radically alter the Earth's climate
or maybe lethal autonomous drones
mass-produced mosquito size killer
bought swarms nanotechnology artificial
general intelligence I mean you you
argue in the paper that it's it's a
matter of luck that when we discovered
that nuclear power could create a bomb
it might have been the case that you
could have created a bomb with with much
easy resources accessible to anyone yeah
so so I think think back to the 1930s so
for the first time we make some
breakthroughs in nuclear physics
some genius figures out that it's
possible to create a nuclear chain
reaction and then realize this that this
could lead to the bomb right and we do
some more work it turns out that what
you're required to make a nuclear bomb
is highly enriched uranium or plutonium
which are very very difficult materials
to get you need ultra centrifuges you
need reactor is like massive amounts of
energy but suppose it had turned out
instead that had been an easy way to
unlock the energy of the atom that maybe
you know by baking sand in the microwave
oven or something like that you could
have created a nuclear detonation so now
we know that that's physically
impossible right but before you did the
relevant physics how could you have
known how to turn out although couldn't
you argue that
you know for life to evolve on earth
that implied a sort of stable
environment that if it was possible to
create massive nuclear reactions
relatively easily the earth would never
have been stable that we wouldn't be
here at all yeah unless there were some
thing that is easy to do on purpose but
that wouldn't happen by random chance so
they're like things we can easily do we
can stack ten blocks on top of one
another but in nature you're not going
to find like a stack of ten blocks okay
so this is probably the one that many of
us worry about most and yes synthetic
biology is perhaps the quickest route
that we can foresee in our near future
to to get us here yeah and so so think
about what that would have meant if say
anybody by working in their kitchen for
an afternoon could destroy a city it's
it's hard to see how modern civilization
as we know it could have survived that
because in any population of a million
people there will always be some who
would for whatever reason choose to use
that destructive power so if if that
apocalyptic residual would choose to
destroy a city or worse than say this
would get destroyed so here's here's
another type of vulnerability talk about
this yeah so in addition to these kind
of obvious types of black balls that you
just make it possible to blow up a lot
of things other types would act by
creating bad incentives for humans to do
things that are harmful so the type to a
I call it that is to think about some
technology that incentivizes great
powers to use their massive amounts of
force to create destructions they think
thing is it so the nuclear weapons were
actually very close to this right what
we did we spent over ten trillion
dollars to build 70,000 nuclear warheads
and put them on a hair-trigger alert and
there were several times during the Cold
War we almost blew each other up it's
not because a lot of people felt this
would be a great idea let's all spend 10
trillion dollars to blow ourselves up
but the incentives were such that we
were finding ourselves I did this could
have been worse right so imagine if
there had been a safe first strike right
then it might have been very tricky in a
crisis situation to refrain from
launching all their nuclear missiles if
nothing else because you would fear that
the other side might do
mutual assured destruction kept the Cold
War relatively stable without that we
might not have been more unstable than a
class yeah and there could be other
properties of technology it could have
been harder for example to have arms
treaties if if instead of nuclear
weapons like there had been some smaller
thing or something less thinking and as
well as bad incentives for powerful
actors you also worried about bad
incentives for all of us in type to be
here yeah so so here we might take the
case of global warming there are a lot
of little conveniences that cause each
one of us to do things that individually
has no significant effect right but if
billions of people do it cumulatively it
has a damaging effect now global warming
could have been a lot worse than it is
we have the climate sensitivity
parameter right it it's a parameter that
says how much warmer does it get if you
emit a certain amount of greenhouse
gasses but suppose that it had been the
case that with the amount of greenhouse
gasses we make it instead of the
temperature rising by say between three
and four point five degrees by 2100
suppose it had been 15 degrees or 20
degrees like then we might have been in
a very bad situation or supposed that
renewable energy had just been a lot
harder to do or that had been more
fossil fuels in the ground
Millikan couldn't you argue that if in
that case of if what we're doing today
had resulted in 10 degrees difference
within the next in the time period that
we could see actually humanity would
have got off its ass and done something
about it was stupid but we're not maybe
that stupid on it but yeah you could you
could you could imagine other features
so right now it's a little bit difficult
to switch to renewables and stuff right
but you camp it on but might just have
been with slightly different physics it
could have been much more expensive to
do these things and what's it what's
your view do you think putting these
these possibilities together that this
humanity that we are we count as a
vulnerable world that there is a death
ball in our future it it's hard to say I
mean I think there might well be various
black
balls in the urn that's what it looks
like there might also be some golden
balls that that would help us protect
against black balls and I don't know
which which order they will come out I
mean one one possible philosophical
critique of this idea is that it it
implies a view that the future is is
essentially settled that there either is
that ball there or it's not and and in a
way that's not a view of the future that
I want to believe I want to I want to
believe that the future is undetermined
that our decisions today will determine
what kind of balls we pull out of that
urn I mean if we if we just keep
inventing like a venture we'll pull out
all the balls right I mean I think
there's a kind of weak form of
technological determinism that is quite
plausible like you're unlikely to
encounter a society that uses Flint axes
and jet planes but you can almost think
of a technology as a set of affordances
the technology is the thing that enables
us to do various things and achieve
various effects in the world now how we
then use that of course depends on human
choice but if we think about these three
types of vulnerability they make quite
weak assumptions about how we would
choose to use them so I type one
vulnerability again right it's massive
destructive power it's a fairly weak
assumption to think that in a population
of millions of people that will be some
that we choose to use it destructively I
mean for me the most single disturbing
argument is that we actually might have
some kind of view into the urn that
makes it actually very likely that we're
doomed namely that it's like if you
believe in accelerating power that
technology inherently accelerates that
we build the tools that make us more
powerful then at some point you get to a
stage where a single individual can take
us all down and then it looks like we're
we're we're screwed isn't that argument
quite alarming yeah I think yeah we get
more power and easier and easier to use
those powers but we can also invent
technologies that kind of help us
control how people use those powers so
let's talk about that let's talk about
the response suppose that looking
thinking about all the possibilities
that are out there now with this it's
not just sin bio it's things like cyber
warfare artificial intelligence etc etc
that there might be serious doom in our
future what what are the possible
responses and you've talked about four
possible responses here's one so
restricted technological development
doesn't seem promising if we're talking
about a general halt to technical
progress I think neither feasible nor
nor would it be desirable even if we
could do it I think there might be very
limited areas where maybe you would want
slower technology called progress you
don't I think one has to progress in bio
weapons or in say isotope separation
that would make it easier to create
nukes I mean I I used to be fully on
board with that but I I would like to
actually push back on that for it for a
minute just because like first of all if
you look at the history of the last
couple decades you know it's always been
you know push forward at full speed it's
okay that's our only choice but if you
look at globalization and the rapid
acceleration of that if you look at the
kind of the strategy of move fast and
break things and what happened with that
and then you look at the potential for
synthetic biology I don't know that we
should move forward rapidly or without
any kind of restriction to a world where
you could have you know a DNA printer in
every home in high school lab is right I
mean there's the first part be not
feasible if you think it would be
desirable to stop it there's still a
problem of feasibility I mean so it
doesn't really help if one nation kind
of no it doesn't help if one nation does
but we've had we've had
treaties before that's how that's really
how we survived the nuclear threat was
by going out there and going through the
painful process of negotiating it I just
wonder whether there isn't like the
logic isn't that we as a matter of
global priority we shouldn't go out
there and try and like now start
negotiating really strict rules on where
synthetic bio research is done that it's
it's not something that you want to
democratize now I mean I I totally agree
with that that
it would be desirable for example maybe
to have DNA synthesis machines not as a
product where each lab has their own
device but maybe as his service maybe
that could be four or five places in the
world we ascend in your digital
blueprint and the DNA comes back right
and then you would have the ability if
one day it really looked like it was
necessary you would have like a finite
set of choke points so I think you won't
want to look for kind of special special
opportunities where you could kinda
write your belief is fundamentally we we
are not going to be successful in so
just holding back researching as someone
somewhere North Korea or you know
someone is going to go there and
discover this this knowledge if it's
there to be found
it looks plausible under current
conditions and I mean it's not just
synthetic power either I mean it's an
any kind of profound change in the world
could turn out so let's look at another
possible yeah so this also I think has
only limited potential so with the type
one vulnerability again I mean if you
could reduce the number of people who
are incentivized to destroy the world if
only they could get access under means
that that would be good so in this in
this image which you asked us to do so
you're imagining these drones flying
around the world actual recognition when
they spot someone showing signs of
sociopathic behavior they shower I think
it's like a hybrid picture like
eliminate could either mean like
incarcerate or kill or it could be
persuade them to a better view of the
world but the point is that suppose you
were extremely successful in this and
you reduced the number of such
individuals by half and if you want to
do it by persuasion I mean you're
competing against all other powerful
forces that are trying to persuade
people party is really doing it like
education system but suppose you could
reduce it by half I don't think the risk
would be reduced by half it would be
maybe reduced by 5 or 10% you know
recent reminding that we gamble
humanity's future on response to I think
it's all good to try to deter and
persuade people but we shouldn't rely on
that as our only safeguard how about
three so I think there are two general
methods that we could use to achieve the
ability to stabilize the world against
the whole spectrum of possible
vulnerabilities and we probably would
need both so one is
an extremely effective ability to do
preventive policing such that you could
intercept if anybody started to do this
dangerous thing right
you could intercept them in real time
and stop them so this would require
ubiquitous surveillance everybody would
be monitored all the time in order to
report essentially I would have like
maybe AI algorithms big freedom centers
that were you know reviewing this etc
etc you know that mass surveillance is
like that's not a very popular term
right now yeah yeah so this little
device there so I imagine a kind of
necklace that you would have to wear at
all times with multi-directional cameras
but to make it go down better like just
call it the freedom tag or something
like that oh okay I mean this this is
the conversation a friends I mean this
is why this is this is such a mind I
mean I think there's a whole big
conversation on this on it someone
obviously I mean let's look at huge
problems and risks with that right but
yeah we may come back to that so the
other the final the other sort of
general stabilization capability is kind
of plugging another governance gap so
the surveillance would be kind of
governance gap at the micro level by
preventing anybody from ever doing
something highly illegal then there is a
corresponding governor's gap at the
macro level at the global level you'd
need the ability reliably to prevent the
worst kinds of global coordination
failures to avoid wars between great
powers arms races cataclysmic Commons
problems in order to deal with the type
2a vulnerabilities I mean global
governance is the term that's definitely
way out of fashion right now but could
you make the case throughout history the
history of humanity is that at every
stage of technological power increase
people have reorganized and and and sort
of centralize the power so for example
when you had when a roving band of
criminals could take over a society the
response was what you have a
nation-state and you centralized force
or the police force or an army so no you
can't do that the logic
HAP's of having a single person or a
single group able to take out humanity
means we're gonna have to go this route
at least in some form now I mean you
certainly true that the scale of
political organization has increased
over the course of human history used to
be hunter-gatherer bands right and then
chiefdom city-states nations now there
are international organizations and so
on and so forth
I mean again I want to mean just make
sure I get the chance to stretch that
obviously there are huge downsides and
indeed massive risks both to mass
surveillance and to global governance
I'm just pointing out that if we are
lucky the world could be such that these
would be the only ways you could survive
a black ball so in the logic of this
theory it seems to me is that is that
we've got to recognize we can't have it
all that the sort of the I would say
naive dream that many of us had that ya
know technology's always gonna be a
force for good keep going don't stop go
as fast as you can and not pay attention
to some of the consequences that's
actually just not an option we can we
can we can have that if we have that
we're going to have to accept some of
these other very uncomfortable things
with it and kind of be in this arms race
with ourselves of you know you want the
power
you better limit it you better figure
out how to limit it I mean I think it is
an option a very tempting option it's in
a sense the easiest option right and it
might work but it means we are
fundamentally vulnerable to extracting a
black ball now I think with a bit of
coordination like if you did solve this
macro governance problem and the micro
governance problem then then I mean we
could extract all the balls from the urn
and we'd benefit greatly I mean if we're
living in this simulation does it matter
you just reboot
I didn't say that
so what's your view like putting all the
pieces together how likely is it that
we're doomed well it's I love popping up
a lot but you asked that question on an
individual level I mean we seem to kind
of be doomed anyway like just with a
time lag from from the we're rotting and
aging and all kinds of things right so I
mean it's actually a little bit tricky I
mean if you want to set up so you can
detach it from ability I mean first who
are we like so if you're very all and
probably you'll die of natural causes
right if you're very young you might
have a hundred year so the probability
might depend on you yes then the
threshold like what counts as
civilizational devastation in the paper
I don't require an existential
catastrophe in order for it to count
this is just a definitional matter right
I say a billion dead or a reduction of
world in ep about fifty percent but
depending on what you say the threshold
is you get a different probability
estimates but I guess I mean you could
put me down as a frightened optimist
you're frightened optimist and I think
you've just created a large number of
other frightened people in the
simulation in a simulation Nick Bostrom
your mind amazes me thank you so much
for scaring the living daylights out of
[Applause]